and welcome to Hannity and tonight The
cdc's credibility is in the toilet and
it is now circling the drain with the
American people in what is now yet
another policy reversal the CDC is now
recommending that unvaccinated and
vaccinated Americans wear masks
indefinitely they're also demanding that
children of all ages wear masks in
school indefinitely and Biden meanwhile
is floating Mac vaccine mandates a new
lockdowns for federal employees we'll
explain all of this coming up now you
see where this is headed you see that
the cowards and the administration
they're in a full panic mode they don't
seem to be as interested in quote the
science Mantra anymore we'll explain all
of this coming up but first we begin
tonight with the latest political
charade on Capitol Hill and that is
Nancy Pelosi's January 6 commission and
literally it has one Mission and one
mission on only oh let's see if we can
impeach and smear and slander and Donald
Trump one more time and of course the
GOP one more time on National Television
to that end the likes of Adam's shift to
congenital liar Adam kinziger Lynn's
chain Liz Cheney and every other
trump-hating politician they're now hard
at work all the evidence points to this
being a biased one-sided investigation
with a predetermined outcome now
Congressman Jim Jordan and Congressman
Jim Banks they were barred from the
committee and to be clear very clear
we've always condemned the unlawful Riot
what happened on January the 6th what
happened on that day can never ever
happen again why that's the people's
house our institutions and every
lawmaker doesn't matter what your
politics are they must be protected
attacks on law enforcement are never and
should never be acceptable ever not at
the Capitol and not any anywhere
remember last summer violent riots
rocked almost every major American city
even the White House was besieged it got
so bad there the Secret Service was
forced to evacuate the president and his
family next door the historic St John's
Church that was lit on fire hundreds of
other buildings throughout the country
were being targeted by these radical
arsonists of federal courthouse and
Portland was vandalized and lit on fire
on multiple occasions a police precinct
in Minneapolis yeah that was burned to
the ground in case you forgot nearly a
hundred police cars were torched over 2
000 plus police officers were injured
rioters pelting bricks and rocks and
Frozen water bottles and Molotov
cocktails 25 Americans were killed
during these riots last summer retired
police captain David Dorn remember he
was murdered by looters in St Louis
while working Security in a local store
remember 10 teenager Horace Lorenzo
Anderson Jr remember he was murdered in
the autonomous Seattle Jazz chop Summer
of Love spaghetti potluck dinner zone
right near a police precinct that had
that the city surrendered to the to the
rioters at that point that delinquent
mayor of Seattle Jenny Durkin never even
bothered to reach out to the victim's
family until Horace Lorenzo Anderson
senior appeared on this show Joe Biden
made no mention of last Summer's
574 violent riots during the DNC not one
word Kamala Harris not only did she not
condemn them she was busy promoting a
bail fund to help the rioters get out of
jail quicker on Twitter other Democrats
they either said nothing or downplayed
the violence and in some cases even
actively supporting the violence where's
this commission as you watch this
disrespectfully should that be done by a
commission or the city council not
involved in the middle of the night
throwing it into the harbor we will do
what they do violence across the whole
country do you disavow the violence from
antifa that's happening in Portland
right now that's right that's a myth
it's
spread only in Washington DC about
antifa in Portland yes they're not going
to stop before election day in November
and they're not going to stop after
election day and that should be everyone
should take note of that on both levels
that this isn't they're not going to let
up and they should not this is a mostly
a protest uh it is not it is not
generally speaking unruly but fires have
been started there needs to be unrest in
the streets for as long as there is
unrest in our lives and unfortunately
there's plenty to go around
they're not going to stop they're not
going to let up and you better take note
of that nor should they stop needless to
say there was no Congressional
Commission on last Summer's
574 officially declared riots all around
the countries and the Democrats were
almost completely silent or even
complicit and supportive dozens were
killed thousands were injured hundreds
of businesses were burned to the ground
widespread looting widespread vandalism
but Democrats they didn't care one bit
it's not politically what expedient for
them so it's not a priority for them if
you were injured if you lost a loved one
or you watched your business get looted
or burned to the ground you're not a
priority no need for a commission in
Nancy Pelosi and our Democratic
colleagues in Congress on this for them
this is you know the house in Washington
in the swamp no they have you know their
house is much more important than your
house or or your business or your
relative that's a police officer or you
that are that are working in police work
still January 6 committee it's not
raising several important questions like
for example where were the
reinforcements why on six separate
occasions six separate requests from the
capitol police chief for additional
security why were they ignored why were
they so unprepared for these massive
riots they knew that there was going to
be a march on the capitol this was a
huge day at the Capitol they knew in
advance they knew the night before
everyone knew that thousands of
demonstrators were descending on
Washington they knew that Mike Pence was
attending the capital in front of a
joint session of Congress so what
happened who was ultimately in charge of
Capital Security in that plan and what
role is the commission going to have
looking into this what role did Nancy
Pelosi the Speaker of the House play
what should her role have been and by
the way those that did trespass and riot
at the Capitol they're now being held
accountable by the FBI on the other hand
574 riots last summer were now hearing
from prosecutors even though we have
overwhelming incontrovertible evidence
video evidence of the crimes they're
committing the vast majority of those
that rioted last summer that we can
identify well we're now told they're not
going to be charged at all is that a
dual system of justice where's the
commission on all the riots all 574 from
last summer why no commission the
Democrats silence at the time and now is
deafening now violence in these major
cities is on the rise this weekend alone
12 were murdered and 70 plus shot in
Chicago and sadly do you know the names
of anybody that's just a typical weekend
in the windy city we have been scrolling
these names since Joe Biden was vice
president and Obama was President and
this was his hometown Democrats they
don't seem to care they don't seem to
care about the names of the what 150 law
enforcement officers killed in the line
of duty so far this year apparently it's
not politically advantageous for them so
they just ignore it it's the same
massive double standard that we always
see on the left they'll say oh we can't
we can't have Russia collusion Russia
Russia Russia unless Hunter Biden is
taking Millions from a Russian oligarch
and the former first lady of Moscow they
didn't seem to care about Russia
collusion when Hillary got the dirty
Russian misinformation dossier that was
used to then spy in a presidential
candidate and a president they staged an
impeachment over a fake Ukrainian quid
pro quo that never happened and ignoring
the real quid pro quo that would be Joe
Biden's quid pro quo that he bragged
about on tape demanding leveraging a
billion taxpayers dollars to get a
prosecutor in Ukraine fired for
investigating a zero experienced son
making millions for nothing and the call
of course they called the Georgia voting
Bill Jim Crow 2.0 now we've weaponized
the doj they're ignoring Delaware's
restrictive voting laws way more
restrictive than Georgia but they're
going after Georgia instead they use the
filibuster over 200 times during Donald
Trump's presidency but now under Biden
they call the filibuster racist and they
demand that you wear a mask and you get
vaccinated and use socially distance and
you follow all the rules while allowing
hundreds of thousands of illegal
immigrants into this country just
processing them without even testing
most of them and a third of them when
offered a vaccine turn it down on this
program we are consistent we condemn
violent riots what happened on January
6th what happened last summer whenever
it happens it must be condemned by
people of Good Will it shouldn't be
political we spoke out against the
brutal murder of George Floyd and of
course David Dorne and and Horace
Lorenzo Anderson Jr and that sad
interview I had with his father
unfortunately Democrats their friends in
the media big Tech media mob they don't
seem to care about truth fairness logic
science Justice for them it's politics
and power that's all that seems to
matter hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else